-Now, this game is called
"Say That To My Face."
-Mm-hmm.
-On your turn,
you're going to hold up
one of these celebrity masks
in front of your face,
like this, okay?
And your partner
has to talk like that person
and give you clues to get
you to guess who you are
as quickly as possible.
When you guess who you are,
you throw your mask away,
and the player
on your right goes next.
There's a random timer,
and if you're holding the
mask when the buzzer goes off...
[ Buzzer ]
...your team loses that round.
And we're gonna play
three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
I'm gonna go here.
You go there.
-I'm so nervous about this.
-This is good.
It's gonna be fun.
It's gonna be good.
-That's not true.
Are you good at this?
-I don't know. We'll see.
-I feel like you are.
You are so full of it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Zachary...
-I start?
-You start us off.
Yes, please.
-Ready?
-3, 2, 1...
-I don't say anything, right?
No.
-Go.
-[ As Schwarzenegger ]
Get to the choppa!
-Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-You got it.
-Now me.
-[ As Seinfeld ]
Okay, people. Okay.
-Jerry Seinfeld.
-Yes.
-Ahh! Ahh! Okay.
-"I have a huge butt
and I'm married to Kanye."
-Kim Kardashian.
-Yep.
-Okay.
Oh. Oh. Oh, oh, oh.
All right, all right, all right!
-Matthew McConaughey.
-Yes!
-[ As De Niro ] Eh...you're
offending me a little bit.
-De Niro?
-Yes.
-Not bad, dude.
-Oh.
♪♪ Do you believe in -- ♪♪
-Cher.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"I'm gonna climb the skyscraper
and kill the
big gorilla right now
in every move that I'm in."
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, damn!
-Yes!
All right.
-That was a hard one.
-I would have never guessed
The Rock anyway.
-All right.
Guys, we got that one.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-I'm psyched about this.
This is fun. This is really fun.
I can tell you're really happy.
-It's fun now.
-This is the best game,
isn't it, man?
-It's a great game.
-Yeah, I love it.
It's so much fun.
All right, Round 2.
Maybe you want to
start us off there, Tariq?
-Oh, yeah. Okay.
-Yeah. All right.
Throw your mask in 3, 2, 1, go.
-[ Russian accent ] I will --
I am -- Trump is my bitch.
-Vladimir Putin.
-Wow.
-Oh, my God!
-You got that. Yeah.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-All right.
-Oh. I can't...
Okay. Oh, god, I can't...
Brah! Brah!
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-"I live in space, on a ship."
Raah!
-Cardi B?
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm really hairy."
[ Growls ]
-Oh, oh. Chewbacca?
-Oh, man.
-Oh!
-"You get a car! You get a car!"
-Oprah!
-Yes. Oh, my God!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-We're tied.
-Tied up!
All right, here we go.
That is officially the
worst impression of Chewbacca
I have ever heard in
my entire life.
Oh, my God!
I thought you were going
like, "O-k-k-k-kay!"
I was like,
"What are you doing?"
"I live in space, on a ship"?
-She's not wrong.
-But then I got it. We got it.
All right, here we go.
-This is so bad.
-All right, here we go.
We're gonna do one final round
for the winner here.
You start it off, pal.
Mila, you're great
at this game.
-No, I suck.
-No. I love you. Please.
-Okay.
-All right, ready?
3, 2, 1, go.
-[ As Cage ] Where? Who?
-What?!
-What's on the back of
a dollar bill?
It's secret --
-Oh, the treasure.
-Yeah.
-Nicolas Cage.
-Yes!
-Oh, "Umbrella," singer.
-Rihanna, Rihanna.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-♪♪ Hit me, baby, one more time ♪♪
-Britney!
-Yes!
-"Okay. I think everybody should
have equal distribution --
-Bernie Sanders.
-Hey, that's really good.
[ Speaking gibberish
as Sandler ]
-Oh. Oh, yeah.
What's his name?
Yes. Yes, yes, yes.
Adam Sandler.
-Yeah, that's right. Good.
-[ As Reeves ]
I am in "The Matrix."
-Oh, Keanu, Keanu.
-Oh, I have a big butt also!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-Oh, that's
the champs right there,
Zachary Quinto, Tariq Trotter.
My partner, Mila Kunis.